hey guys it is the 25th of every today
which means we are so close to me not
having to pronounce februari anymore
thank god you're watching games begin
some people have been pretty pissed at
nvidia over false advertising claims
some Serpas they've launched a
class-action lawsuit here's what nvidia
have to say about it nvidia executive
son juan has first up to the poor
description of the company's gtx 970 GPU
which suggested better performing
technical specs than the card actually
had the card advertised for gigabytes of
vram but gamers found that it would
struggle with games that use over 3.5
gigs of ram in response to the consumer
confusion Huang explained that Nvidia
had invented a way to increase memory of
the GTX 970 from 3 gigabytes to 4
gigabytes he said the GTX 970 is a full
gigabyte card however the upper 512
megabytes of the additional one gigabyte
is segmented and has reduced bandwidth
this is a good design because we're able
to add an additional one gigabyte for
GTX 970 and our software engineers can
keep less frequently used data in the
512 megabyte segment unfortunately we
failed to communicate this internally to
our marketing team and externally to
reviewers at launch he's promised that
they will do a better job next time but
that's unlikely to serve those involved
in the class action lawsuit a couple of
sources have suggested today that a new
ps4 system update is on its way it's
currently suggested that we will see the
update on or around the 29th of March
that's according to a Sony fan claiming
to have inside sources who just happens
to have a good track record with these
kinds of tidbits that rumored timeline
does seem to fit with a comment from
Fred Dutton a community manager at
stoney who stated on the PlayStation log
that the next update is not too far
out content-wise we're not sure what
will be getting from the update but some
fans are keen to see the promised
suspend resume function which lets
gamers pause and resume games quickly by
powering the console off and on if he
thought all that destiny ps4 share play
drama was done and dusted you were so
wrong but if taken kind of a different
turn with the introduction of Chris who
is a bit of a jerk it's been revealed
that Chris a 17 year old griefer was the
one responsible for deleting the
aforementioned 11 year old couple nights
destiny save files by a share play and
it turns out he wasn't the only victim
of chris's actions spurred on by what i
can only assume is just way too much
free time chris used another person's
ps4 and PSN ID to go to online players
into enabling share play 5 promising to
help them out before going in and
deleting their data as for what he has
to say for himself chris eloquently
states suck it up and move on with life
what else is there to say chris has also
said he's done this on GTA before in
addition to destiny and that he doesn't
care much for the angry outcry from the
internet Bungie had been notified of the
player but hadn't responded to requests
to discuss his actions I'm going to take
a guess that this kid is probably having
a bad time for one reason or another but
taking that out on strangers is
extremely uncool it's also suspected
that Chris may not have been grouping
players alone so be careful of your
accounts people let me know down in the
comments what you think of this whole
fiasco and the offender you can head to
gamespot or we've got news on a fast and
furious sports a horizon game and the
new free EA ax
game that is it for me today I'll be
back with more news tomorrow though so
be sure you check back with me then